2022 has been packed full of great games
from huge blockbusters like elden ring
to smaller titles that might have
slipped under your radar here are 15 of
the best games of 2022 so far
neon white is a game i cannot stop
thinking about it's part first person
shooter part visual novel part card game
and part
speed running tutorial picking up soul
cards gives you access to weapons to
take out demons that have infested
heaven but by burning the cards you get
access to abilities like bombs or a
double jump which will help you complete
the levels even faster the entire game
is built to teach you how to complete
its levels as quickly as you can and
it's incredibly satisfying to unlock ace
medals find each secret and crucially
climb those leaderboards
if you like a schlocky horror game that
wears its references proudly on its
sleeve then the quarry is one for you
made by supermassive games the team
behind until dawn it throws another
group of teens into a scary situation
that not all of them will escape whether
you play alone with others or just set
up some settings so the game makes the
decisions for you and plays out like a
movie the quarry is full of scares and
gruesome moments that will keep you
entertained throughout its run time
regarded as the best kirby game yet
kirby and the forgotten land burst onto
the switch in early 2022. it revitalized
the usual kirby formula with mouthful
mode where he inhales big items like
cars and his body stretches to
accommodate not only is it very funny to
see kirby waddle around as a big cone
but it freshens gameplay by offering new
mechanics throw in delightful puzzles
and platforming and kirby and the
forgotten land is a game for fans young
and old alike
ghost ride tokyo comes from the
development studio behind the evil
within and while it may not be jump out
of your seat scary it's a slow burn of
supernatural spooks mixed with a unique
combat system that packs a punch as
akito you're brought back from the dead
by a mischievous spirit called kk who
grants you access to his powers while
the two of you team up to find out just
what's up with a mysterious fog that's
covered tokyo
horizon forbidden west is the sequel to
2017's zero dawn and once again follows
eloy as she and her companions attempt
to fix a world that was broken by greedy
corporations and a misfiring ai in
forbidden west she travels well
west to find the ancient tech that will
fix earth's biosphere and stop a blight
that threatens to destroy all life if
you enjoyed zero dawn then forbidden
west is more of the same but with more
to do and more characters to get to know
and love
while tunic might remind you of older
legend of zelda titles from its
isometric perspective plus its green
garbed protagonist that has a sword and
shield it actually has more in common
with souls games with tough stamina
based combat and rest points that
respawn enemies tunic requires a lot of
your attention it also has beautiful
level design and also similarly to souls
games doesn't really tell you where to
go or what you should be doing while you
can tune its difficulty in menus you
need to invest time in the game and
collect lost pages from an instruction
manual to piece it all together
speaking of souls like games what is
there to say about elden ring that
hasn't been said already i'm not going
to belabor the point but if souls games
haven't been your thing before i implore
you to give this one a try if its
difficulty is off-putting try an
astrologer build or make great use of
its summoning pools hell even cheese
those bad boys it's a tough game but
it's so rewarding and features some of
the best open world design ever there is
a reason
actually many reasons that it's so
lorded
this one is a real trust me don't look
up anything about this game
recommendation not only would it spoil
the experience it's also just quite
difficult to explain the concept the
stanley parable launched in 2013 but was
updated this year with the ultra deluxe
edition which basically acts as a sequel
to the original a wonderful mix of humor
and commentary on how we play and enjoy
games the stanley parable ultra deluxe
edition is a real must play
okay switch sports may not have all of
the sports of wii sports and wii sports
resort but there's still something
wonderfully nostalgic about seeing me's
bowling together the game features
football tennis bowling badminton
chambara and volleyball with golf due to
be added as a free update later this
year if you want to climb the ranks and
best your buds on the court then this is
the one for you
since its launch in 2017 destiny 2 has
received frequent massive updates and
2022's the witch queen was just that
featuring a ton of new content from
missions and gear to a whole new raid
while the story might go over the heads
of new players who maybe haven't watched
a recap first returning players will be
rewarded with some of the game's best
story moments yet
nobody saves the world is a dungeon
crawler with one of the most satisfying
gameplay loops i've experienced starting
the game as the eponymous nobody quickly
you gain a magic wand and the ability to
shapeshift into different creatures and
characters you can be a rat or a massive
dragon but each form has useful and
unique abilities and you can mix and
match them to create customized builds
you can either play alone or with a
friend but regardless it's a wild
adventure
if you want to shoot nazis in the dick
then boy do i have the game for you
sniper elite 5 is the latest in
rebellion's long running series and
while it'll be familiar fair if you've
played one before there are plenty of
new additions like more in-depth weapon
customization and multiplayer invasions
to keep it feeling fresh and interesting
teenage mutant ninja turtles shredders
revenge walks a tight line of retaining
the feel of the classic beat-em-up games
that the turtles appeared in while also
freshening up the formula for a 2022
audience the result is a game that's a
love letter to all things tmnt but also
feels fantastic to play it's packed full
of easter eggs for turtles fans to
uncover and it's an absolute blast to
play in co-op with friends just be
warned you'll be hearing that theme song
in your head for days afterwards
norco is very different to most other
games on this list both in terms of
gameplay and aesthetic but it's one that
certainly shouldn't be missed a
point-and-click adventure game set in
south louisiana norco's story is set
around k who returns to the town to sort
through the affairs of her recently
deceased mother and to track down her
missing brother the story starts simply
but quickly a huge mystery begins to
unravel around kaye and her family
dystopian whimsical and dark this
adventure game will stick with you long
after the credits have rolled don't miss
it
okay this one is technically cheating
because monster hunter rise came out
last year on the nintendo switch however
2022 saw its pc release which our
reviewer richard wakeling calls the
definitive version monster hunter as a
franchise is absolutely massive just
look at its sales figures and steam
concurrents but it has been accused of
being unwelcoming to new players
something that has been somewhat
remedied by ryze's more approachable
nature you still kill giant monsters but
now it's easier and quicker to get into
the action the pc port delivers high
quality textures and it runs much more
smoothly than its nintendo switch
counterpart it's on this list not only
because it's a fantastic port but
because of the huge new sunbreak
expansion which adds new quests areas
monsters and a new big monster to hunt
the elder dragon malzino if you've been
wary of playing monster hunter before
now this is the time to jump in
there you have it 15 of the best games
released this year so far there are
plenty of huge exciting releases set to
come including call of duty modern
warfare gotham knights and the callisto
protocol we'll always have the latest
sofa more on these games and even more
drop us a like and subscribe to gamespot
on youtube i'm on twitter at lucy james
games and i'll catch you next time